everyone is a human being and they
should feel everyone should feel like
they have the opportunity to contribute
to something bigger than themselves
there's a wonderful story from the
Saturn 5 rocket program where a
journalist was walking around Cape
Canaveral and saw somebody with a NASA
badge and said can I just interview you
for this story I'm writing and he says
so what do you what do you what what's
all this what are you doing what are you
contributing to me and he talked about
the power of going to the moon and how
proud he was to be a part of this and at
the end of the interview the journalist
said what's your job he said I'm the
janitor and it's an amazing thing to
visit a company where the receptionist
feels as much a part of the cause as the
engineer but we all play different roles
and I think it's very important for a
leader an executive a bandage or a boss
whatever word you want to use to remind
people of their of their real value not
their generic value yeah not like you're
helping contribute to something but
rather you're helping make you know you
know the economy which company it was
they they gave their receptionist a
business card and it said chief of first
impressions
[Music]